it's a lot to remember my memories sure
good morning belief nation today we're
going to talk about how to learn
accelerated learning is important to me
because I realized at a very young age I
was the runt of the litter
I grew up us very small as born
premature got my ass kicked all over the
place
and where I could exert my my control or
shape my own destiny was through
learning and using books documentaries
biographies mentors in some cases as an
Archimedes lever we're easy even as this
tiny little kid I could get good grades
I get out debate I could make things
right things create things that other
people couldn't and I mean I've seen
people do impossible things and I've
seen people just in the last few months
who have never been come from putting
their face underwater in you know three
or four days go from not being able to
swim one lap to swimming a half a mile
on the open ocean the learning language
is well enough to go on live TV and be
interviewed in three or four days I've
seen just ridiculous stuff and it
doesn't require that you have some
special gift it requires that you find a
special toolkit and all that's related
to accelerated learning
whenever you don't learn it's because
someone is trying to teach you in a
different way and the different way is I
was a good student in school I liked
learning until I got junior high school
high school where I liked all subjects
until I got to there when math became
algebra geometry and trigonometry
because when I got there I totally hated
it so I had no motivation to really
learn it and with no drive to learn
something you know but then secondly
since I wasn't driven it was also the
class that usually had the most homework
and if you didn't in the homework and
you came in the next day it was like
being in a foreign language class by
hypotenuse of X Y Z over and I'm here
yeah my brain searching don't know what
that is so then I would raise my hand to
ask question she's not a good thing to
do in that environment so I'd say well
what is a hypotenuse and they go oh our
super duper - without that you don't
know that's really like hoppin hoppin
about it you don't know so if you want
to learn something if you're not
learning it's not that you're not smart
it's not that you can't figure it out
it's that the person is explaining it
using references you don't have so I've
learned things like quantum physics I've
learned things like nuclear power from
physicists I'll say okay explain to me
how that's like an orange house that
least like a solar system something I
understand and sure enough once they
make that linkage you got it you
understand the relationship you
understand what things are if you want
to learn something you need to be able
to model something you need be able to
see somebody who's already done it you
need to be able to read about somebody
who's already done it you need to
experience somebody who's already done
it you have to not start from scratch
the worst thing you can do in learning
is start from scratch because with no
foundation of what's worked before
you're just making stuff up and you're
reinventing the wheel and that's the
slowest way to learn because you know
the wheel is invented a couple thousand
years ago so the worst thing you can do
is say well let me just go start trying
a bunch of stuff that's not learning
that's called being an idiot and being
an idiot is about just bumbling through
life without realizing somebody's
already done it for you
so go read a book about somebody who's
done what you want to do go take a
course from somebody who's already
accomplished what you want to accomplish
go you know follow somebody's online
thing about who's already done what
there's so much example for you to learn
from and it has to begin with that
because if you have the dream you have
the goal of what you want to learn and
how it mean something to your life once
you've got that goal now it's about okay
go learn from somebody who already did
it that will give you a leg up so fast
if you're like what is education like
you're basically downloading data and
algorithms into your brain and it's it's
actually amazingly bad in conventional
education because like it shouldn't be
like this huge tour so you're making it
way way better but I mean I think I
think a lot of things that I would say
it you've probably heard a hundred times
and in effect or if not doing like the
more you can gamify the process of
learning the better like for my kids I
do not have to encourage them to play
video games yeah okay I feel like pry
them from their hands it's like like a
crack yes yes like drop that crack
needle yeah so it's yeah it's it's it's
the degree that you can make somehow
learning like a game it's better
and I think unfortunately like a lot of
education is very vaudvillian
at you've got someone standing up there
kinda of lecturing at people and they've
done the same lecture twenty years in a
row and they're excited about it
and that lack of enthusiasm you know is
conveyed to the students that they're
not very excited about it
I don't know why they're there like why
are we learning this stuff we don't even
know why in fact I think a lot of things
people learn probably there's no point
in learning them because if they never
use them in the future because who's
gonna launch a rocket into space I mean
that's just like yeah exactly that never
happens well you have to say like people
I think don't stand back and say well
why are we teaching people these things
and we should tell them probably why
we're teaching those things
a lot of kids just in school kinda
puzzled as to why they're there
and I think if you can explain the why
of things then that makes a huge
difference to people's motivation
yeah then they understand the understan
purpose yeah so think that's pretty
important and just make make it
entertaining
my question is I want that right how
long does it take from starting
something and being grossly incompetent
and knowing it to being reasonably good
and hopefully a short a period of time
as possible so how long does that take
here's what my research says 20 hours
that's it you can go from knowing
nothing about any skill that you can
think of want to learn language want to
learn how to draw want to learn how to
juggle flaming chainsaws if you put 20
hours of focused deliberate practice
into that thing you will be astounded
astounded at how good you are 20 hours
is doable that's about 45 minutes a day
for about a month even skipping a couple
days here and there 20 hours isn't that
hard to accumulate now there's a method
to doing this because it's not like you
can just start filling around for about
20 hours and expect these massive
improvements there's a way to practice
intelligently there's a way to practice
efficiently that will make sure that you
invest those 20 hours in the most
effective way that you possibly can and
here's the method it applies to anything
the first is to deconstruct the skill
decide exactly what you want to be able
to do when you're done and then look
into the skill and break it down into
smaller and smaller pieces most of the
things that we think of as skills are
actually big bundles of skills that
require all sorts of different things
the more you can break apart the skill
the more you're able to decide what are
the parts of
skill that will actually help me get to
what I want and then you can practice
those first and if you practice the most
important things first you'll be able to
improve your performance in the least
amount of time possible
the second is learn enough to self
correct so get three to five resources
about what it is you're trying to learn
could be books could be DVDs could be
courses could be anything but don't use
those as a as a way to procrastinate on
practice I I know I do this right get
like 20 books about the topic is like
I'm gonna start learning how to program
a computer when I complete these 20
books
no that's procrastination what you want
to do is learn just enough that you can
actually practice and self correct or
self edit as you practice so the
learning becomes a way of getting better
at noticing when you're making a mistake
and then doing something a little
different
the third is to remove barriers to
practice distractions television
internet all of these things that get in
the way of you actually sitting down and
doing the work and the more you're able
to use just a little bit of willpower to
remove the distractions that are keeping
you from practicing the more like you
like likely you are to actually sit down
and practice right and the fourth is to
practice for at least 20 hours now most
skills have what I call a frustration
barrier
you know the grossly incompetent knowing
it part that's really really frustrating
we don't like to feel stupid
and feeling stupid is a barrier to us
actually sitting down and doing the work
so by pre committing to practicing
whatever it is that you want to do for
at least 20 hours you will be able to
overcome that initial frustration
barrier and stick with the practice long
enough to actually reap the rewards all
right that's it it's not rocket science
four very simple steps that you can use
to learn
anything intellectual understanding is
the level of learning that most people
go for oh I kind of know that but
knowing and not doing is the same as not
knowing would you agree so why do most
people do it this is the expensive
notebook I was talking about earlier and
there's a specific reason for it I'm
going to chunk it down quickly and then
I'm gonna hand back to Brian and I just
want to make you aware of what's going
on when we just go to learn something
cuz there's more to it than there's just
sitting there trying to read something
but the first level of intellectual
understanding means nothing means what
nothing smokers no they shouldn't smoke
they're smokers aren't only intellectual
people you know everybody no there's no
logical argument you can construct on
this planet right now for why you should
set fire to something toxic stick it in
your mouth and suck the fumes sorry guys
I mean yeah 50 years ago the doctors
were telling you to do it right now
we're a little more aware right now
again not picking on the smokers as such
although I am okay but what I'm saying
is smokers know they shouldn't smoke ya
know we can get into habit conditioning
and different levels of cause and and
needs that and that's a separate
conversation but for purposes of of this
analogy as intellectual understanding
doesn't mean they're not going to smoke
correct what causes somebody to stop
smoking is the second level where it
starts to deepen and we go from
intellectual understanding to emotional
understanding when something you feel
something where rather than just the
thinking sexy kicks in the thinking
center the feeling Center gets kicked in
then all of a sudden you compelled to
take action now instead of me saying oh
yeah I should give up I should go to the
gym yeah your six-year-old daughter
comes up looks and says daddy please
give up smoking I don't want you to die
I want you to walk me up the aisle at my
wedding and I throw everything you're
gonna make it and runs off crying it's
like yeah or you go to the doctor's and
he says all these headaches you've been
having we've had the blood tests back
and I'm afraid to say that if you take
one more cigarette you could suffer a
fatal stroke
now did you suddenly become more
intelligent about smoking no you didn't
learn something new but you went from
intellectual understanding to now
whoa I get it penny drops yeah that
level of emotional trigger is really
what's required for most people to start
to act differently otherwise it's just
intellectual which means you you can
probably sound smart at a cocktail party
but it's not gonna change your life
so emotional understanding is where you
want to get to and that's where the Y
comes in why do you want what it is that
you want what is it you want is it for
the right reasons am I just trying to
prove to my parents that I was good
enough yeah or my my elder brother or
the world or what-have-you but emotional
understanding doesn't give lasting
change
it gives change in the moment what gives
lasting change is understanding getting
through to the third level or the third
stage of deepening the knowledge which
is the identity it becomes part of who
you are it's a cellular level of
learning it's in your DNA it becomes
your identity see if you've got a smoker
right who knows they shouldn't smokes
not gonna do anything if you're gonna
smoke who suddenly like you know it's
out of breath running for the bus and
thinks that's it I'm screwed I'm gonna
change my life emotional the three weeks
later they're still smoking unless they
change their identity and unfortunately
most people at that point become a
smoker whose quit and if you're a smoker
whose quit it's only a matter of time
before you go back because your identity
is you still a smoker and now you're
engaged in willpower because I'm a
smoker but I've quit so someone offers
you cigarettes like there's this push
Paul going on and willpower has a time
limit you know you have all the
willpower in the world to hang onto a
ledge above a cliff but if you come back
in two weeks I'm not there hey that's
but if you change your identity to
become a nonsmoker and somebody offers
you cigarette what do you say it's
effortless there's none of that
push-pull going on so my question for
you before I hand back to Brian is this
when it comes to money success business
what is your identity who are you do you
see yourself as a millionaire or do you
see yourself as somebody who's broke
that wants to make more money to get out
of pain do you see yourself as somebody
that's committed to learning and willing
to embrace looking stupid incompetence
not good enough and all of the emotions
that most people run from because you
know what's on the other side or is it
just gonna be well I'll take the class
and then for it's the world's fault if I
don't make it these are the questions
that one has to ask and be honest with
yourself as Brian said being a humble
student because at that level everything
starts to change thank you so much for
watching we made this video because
Emanuel Hernandez asked us to if you
have a topic you'd like Evan to cover in
a future episode of the leave life leave
a comment below I'd also love to know
which of the points that we covered
today had the biggest impact on you it's
gonna maybe spark a change in your life
leave it in the comments below I won't
join the discussion thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon